now on good day accused murderer Robert
tell is back in the spotlight but will
he keep his County position in
six-figure salary that is for a judge to
decide
smoke detectors may be an annoyance at
the wrong time but it actually check
them and make sure that they work they
could save your life we'll have your
details for you for fire prevention
month
and it's day three of Donnie Osmond week
from being on stage two taking out the
garbage Donnie talks about his home life
and how he met his beautiful wife
they've been married more than four
decades Cote Las Vegas starts right now
now this is good day Las Vegas live
local now smack dab in the middle of the
week we appreciate you joining us here
on a Wednesday it is six o'clock time to
get up and Adam grab that coffee I don't
know Sherry it might almost be time for
iced coffee still right we're kind of
still in that iced coffee Zone oh well
for the afternoon this morning warm
coffee is probably fine but just make
sure you're drinking lots of water too
and do it first thing in the morning so
you don't get behind because air is
starting to dry out a little bit more
isn't that gorgeous as we look off to
the east nice clear skies now yesterday
we had a gorgeous Sunrise too with a few
clouds around but no clouds this morning
72 degrees we're running a few degrees
cooler than we were yesterday at this
hour still a little over 30 percent
humidity in the dew point at 41. really
33 percent humidity as we get cooler
that's not a big deal but it's the dew
point that we watch to really tell how
much moisture is in the air so that will
drop as we get through the day and even
more so go into the next day or two
Sunrise 6 39 and 6 18 is the sunset so
we're looking for about almost 80
degrees by mid-morning lots of good
Sunshine for your Wednesday stay
hydrated get some sunscreen on if you're
going to be outdoors a lot mid 80s by
noon and sliding all the way back into
those extra warm 90s we should be right
around 86 for the afternoon high so
we'll certainly beat that after the noon
hour it's going to be a warm Wednesday
but there are cooler changes on the way
I'll cover those coming up right now
Nate's got his eye on the drive good
morning Nate Good morning Sherry and
we're looking here at the I-15 because
it is for sure slowing down we've got
waves of very heavy traffic stopping on
the 15 coming out of the spaghetti Bowl
heading down towards Sahara and Beyond
let's take a live look show you lanes
are open you just have a ton of company
now an earlier crash in the near
Southwest Valley at Decatur and the 215.
that's long gone but the live camera
there highlights what's been going on
there for weeks and that is the co
phones that have Northbound Decatur down
to just one lane so this across the top
of your screen is the 215 Southern
Beltway these folks the headlights are
northbounders the taillights are
southbound there's been a lot of
construction if you drive around there
I'm not telling you anything new but
give yourself some extra time Decatur
and sunset Heather oh we're a good
reminder Nate we appreciate that this
morning County Representatives will be
in court to continue their efforts to
remove public administrator Robert
Tellis from his position this is he
stands accused of killing Las Vegas
Review Journal investigative reporter
Jeff Garman currently Telus is still
making his 120 thousand dollar a year
salary while he's in jail the county
argues since the charges were filed
Telus has not fulfilled his job
responsibilities and was neglect full of
office telus's lawyer initially
requested time to respond that hearing
continues today Sherry this morning
President Biden and first lady Biden are
due in Florida where they'll get a
first-hand look at the devastation left
behind by Hurricane Ian as communities
there continue rescue and Aid work and
the death toll climbs here's Astrid
Martinez
the White House says when President
Biden visits Fort Myers Florida this
morning to survey the destruction and
meet with First Responders and local
residents politics will not play a role
that includes during a planned meeting
with Governor Ron DeSantis one of the
president's most prominent Republican
critics they're going to talk about what
what how what else needs what else are
the needs in Florida to get to a place
of recovery to get to a place of
rebuilding Ian's flood waters are
receding but in some areas the recovery
effort is just getting underway there's
more urban search and rescue capability
in Florida since this storm than has
ever been in one place and one state
since 9 11. a week after the category 4
hurricane first made landfall in the U.S
rescue teams continue to go door to door
in search of both victims and survivors
we want to get to those that have
um run out of medication those who have
been they're trapped in their homes
because of the debris and trying to
either get them out on a check on their
well-being the extent of the damage is
still being assessed specially in
coastal communities that took a direct
hit from Ian manufactured homes
ripped to shreds hundreds of thousands
of homes and businesses remain without
power getting the lights back on is a
priority but officials say the task
could take a month or more to complete
Astrid Martinez CBS News New York
Ian is already blamed for at least 102
deaths in Florida and four more in North
Carolina officials believe those numbers
will continue to grow higher in the days
to come Nate even though we are
thousands of miles away from Ian we can
help the American Red Cross the Southern
Nevada urging all of us to step up and
give blood the storm in Florida shutting
down blood donation centers so they got
a shortage as always Universal type O
blood is the most in demand and there
are several blood drives going on here
in southern Nevada there's one today at
the Wells Fargo Bank at Sahara and
Rainbow to make an appointment go to Red
crossblood.org Heather yeah we've been
in such a critical shortage Nate thank
you this morning ccsd's embattled
superintendent could have more job
security the school district will vote
on Dr Jesus jara's new agreement during
a Board of Trustees work session last
Thursday they gave the superintendent an
A on their annual evaluation this after
he was fired and then rehired late last
year the New Deal would include a 75
thousand dollar annual raise increasing
his salary to 395 thousand dollars a
year that would run through 2026.
Elon musk's on again off-again planned
to buy Twitter came to an end yesterday
that's when the Tesla CEO finally agreed
to purchase the 44 billion dollar social
network the move comes just two weeks
before Twitter's board and musk were set
to go to court Twitter sued musk after
he previously tried to pull out of that
deal while the deal may be done Twitter
did not say if it would drop the lawsuit
against musk some logistical and legal
hurdles still remain but musk could have
control of Twitter here in the next
couple of days
they had the worst influenza season over
the past five years
that's Dr William shaffner the director
of the national foundation for
infectious diseases talking about the
flu season in Australia so the
experience down under could be ahead of
what's to come here in the U.S one of
the big concerns lower flu vaccination
rates in recent years
the lowest flu vaccination coverage we
have seen in children in the last eight
seasons
Dr Rachelle wolensky is the director of
The Centers for Disease Control there's
a national survey that shows less than
half of all adults are planning to get a
flu shot by the way pregnant women and
kids also getting fewer flu vaccinations
now you want to schedule one lots of
information on our website 8newsnow.com
prior just two weeks ago it's a very
difficult reminder of how critical it is
to practice and prepare your family for
emergencies it is fire prevention month
our Candace Charles joining us live now
at the Clark County building department
with some tips that will help keep you
and your family safe Candace good
morning lots to talk about here
yes Heather good morning to you good
morning folks it really is all about
keeping your family safe you want to
have three main things a plan
of course your smoke detector and a fire
extinguisher now we've been showing you
this morning how this works we started
out trying to get this working I have
the fire inspector here with me Nick
giulito and we started out with it not
working but there's a specific reason
right tell us why yeah well what we look
for is we look for things that are
damaged on smoke or on fire
extinguishers a couple times here and
the reason why this one didn't work is
because we have a bent gauge right here
and whatever charges this probably
leaked out we did test it earlier at
work so there's plenty of Aging in it
right so you assume they work right but
they don't right that's definitely an
example of what you need to do to make
sure that it does work next we want to
talk about smoke detectors now maybe
they're annoyed sometimes it beeps at
you he said something important though I
think you want to make sure your kids
are ready for plans what should you do
I think every now and then we should
have unannounced smoke detector and fire
drills in the house so just go up to it
push it they'll all go off and see if
your kids go out to their predetermined
locations you should have two okay and
how often should you change these
batteries that's important to remember
folks just like a fire extinguisher the
smoke detector is only good for about 10
years batteries we like to change twice
a year every six months perfect thank
you so much Nick we appreciate all that
you do coming up we're going to be
running some drills so you guys can know
how to make this plan for you and your
family keep your kids safe of course we
got to cover all these details on our
website amnewsnow.com for now I'm
Candace Charles 8 News Now
think those smoke detectors those sounds
are annoying but they save your life
save your life Pride week is officially
underway here in Las Vegas the Annual
Pride Parade will go through downtown
Las Vegas Friday night starts at 7 p.m
you see the streets there fourth and
Bridger starts at seven our own
Christian Casitas will also serve as one
of the events MC looks like it's gonna
be a lot of fun and don't forget the
Raiders and Chiefs this Monday night
right here on Channel 8 with kickoff set
for 5 p.m this is your home for the most
Raiders games and we've secured another
one you've got it Raiders Chiefs here on
Channel 8 this Monday their schedule of
their uh
their uh three in one and one and three
that's what I'm trying to say their
records yes we need another win
come on guys you can do it still ahead
here on good day our tribute to iconic
showman Donnie Osmond continues in this
time he's talking about the love of his
life and what really keeps him grounded
when he is not on stage uh you want to
stick around for this Sherry yes I
always want to hear everything Donny all
the time accurate 8-day forecast for
your Wednesday look at those clear skies
temperatures are in the low 70s now on
our way to the topper 70's through the
morning mid 80's by noon yes an extra
warm Wednesday with highs sliding right
into those 90s it'll take a little while
to cool off but we'll get to 80s again
after dinner time some cooler changes in
your most accurate weather now eight day
forecast it's straight ahead coming
after the break we're live local now
sponsored by the Southern Nevada Water
Authority live
this is good day Las Vegas
now
this week we've been showing you what
it's like to be Donny Osmond as our
Donnie wheat continues you know he's
been a part of Las Vegas for so long he
almost feels like family to many of us
but it's his real family he told me that
keeps him grounded and yes he even does
house chores
you're part of the fabric of this
community yes and this community's been
through a lot no doubt yes what does it
mean to you well I've seen this town
kind of like my career of the ups and
downs and in betweens
I've seen this town when it was
considered a ghost town for
entertainment
that's certainly not the case in 2022
where Las Vegas is the entertainment
capital of the world what's beautiful
about Vegas right now is that it's
better than ever before and Donnie is
loving it when you ask me about the
importance of Las Vegas
it really is the creme de La Creme in in
Show Business my wife and I love being
nevadans right now
Entertainer extraordinaire is is done it
all and now he's raking in the accolades
for his solo show but it's his family he
says that keeps him rooted and when I go
home I take out the garbage mow the lawn
to stuff like that married 44 years
Donnie remembers the moment he knew she
was the one as I was dating a girl by
the name of Tammy and Jay was dating my
wife Debbie we went to an Elton John
concert and when when Elton sat down
it's a little bit funny he was singing
your song I remember looking over at my
brother's date thinking I'm going to
marry that girl someday and two weeks
about two weeks after that double date
we switched he says it's all about
balance because to him family still
comes first
just had our 13th grand baby so life is
great and I don't want to lose that
seems like he's got it all he's
certainly loving it we love having him
as a resident here he says he bought a
house in Summerlin all right coming up
very soon we're giving away tickets to
see Donnie here in Las Vegas four
tickets plus a VIP experience caller
number eight will win we'll put that
number up on the screen here in just a
little while and then you know of course
if you don't win today you still have
tomorrow and Friday and Friday will
include a gift certificate to Ruth's
Chris Steakhouse as well so you get
dinner and a show stay tuned that is
coming up but I gotta check in with
Sherry you're watching something kind of
cool over there oh my goodness it really
is cool we're taking a live picture
right now from nasa.gov as the crew is
uh just about to board the dragon
endurance it's the SpaceX rocket that's
going to carry a crew of four up to the
International Space Station you can see
the countdown uh there it's just behind
our live bug actually about two hours
and 45 minutes before liftoff and
they're just getting the astronauts in
the rocket right now and they are taking
a Russian astronaut with the crew who is
the mission specialist for this flight
up to the International Space Station it
looks like things are pretty clear on
the coast of East Florida this morning
at Kennedy Space Center and again this
is the SpaceX launch pad out there to
Kennedy so all systems go for now as
they load the astronauts into the
endurance rocket there all right we'll
check on them during the hour to see how
things are going we've got clear skies
this morning we're doing fine we're
cooling off into the low 70s and some
60s look at Seven Hills you're down to
64. Henderson's down to 69. 68 at
Mountains Edge and 60s from Summerlin to
Centennial Hills and down to 60 degrees
at Red Rock this morning with cool 50s
up at Kyle Canyon 48 in Caliente this
morning with 50s at Indian Springs 6 54
in Pahrump 65 in Mesquite low 70's for
Boulder City and mid 70s for Laughlin
right now we'll look stay above normal
yesterday we hit 90 today I think with
less humidity and plenty of sunshine
will slide into some low 90s we should
be right there in the mid 80s for
October 5th yesterday we were 100 as the
record high and from now on for the rest
of the year records are in the triple or
in the double digits excuse me no more
triple digit records and I think we're
done with triple digits for the rest of
the year we've turned that corner and I
think we're pretty much done with
monsoon season too now that we're in
October this area of low pressure is
spinning those showers into New Mexico
and the Southern Plains showers and
thunderstorms through the Upper Midwest
you can see how clear it is on the east
coast of Florida this morning and chilly
remnants of Hurricane Ian still spinning
showers into New England my goodness
we'll stay dry high pressure will build
over Nevada from the Pacific Northwest
all the way down to the desert 92 today
light winds but drier and we'll keep it
in those extra warm low 90s into the
first of the weekend then temperatures
slide a little bit into those upper 80s
Mornings in the 60s and after Columbus
Day indigenous people stay on Monday we
might even make it to the low 80s later
next week we've got to get to the
Detroit we've seen some waves of very
heavy traffic southbound on I-15 out of
the spaghetti Bowl uh the 95 515 since
the big squeeze is pretty well wrapped
up not that big a deal but let's take a
live look here at southbound and
Northbound I-15 so the tail lights are
northbounders heading into the spaghetti
Bowl looks like the current wave is not
so bad if you want to get onto the I-15
South not too bad right now and earlier
crash has cleared from near the 215
Southern Beltway at Decatur but man that
is a tough one so we wanted to keep the
camera there
it looks like you have available Lanes
but the 215 Southern beltways near the
top of your screen these headlights are
northbounders on Decatur the cones keep
you restricted to just one lane there so
expect some delays and speaking of
delays what's driving you crazy is next
this injury law Millions recovered
monthly
6 24 on your Wednesday morning what's
driving you crazy well a frequent viewer
email complaint returns with kind of an
unfortunate answer Iris writes
on the 95 Northbound from Rancho to Ann
Road the carpool lanes full of single
drivers speeding past the afternoon
traffic when are they going to get nhp
out there to give these folks tickets
for one driving alone in a carpool lane
and two speeding doesn't make sense to
have a carpool lane if no one adheres to
the law
Iris as we are still reporting today
there are real staffing issues with the
Nevada State Police Highway Patrol the
union representative says a normal shift
has upwards of 14 troopers on the road
this past Saturday they had four and no
one here suggesting drivers disobeyed
the law thank you for riding in Iris
buckle up drive carefully please put
down the phone and join the driving you
crazy conversation at traffic 8 at
8newsnow.com
some trending stories for you this
morning one of the most famous brands of
canned pressed meat is on track for an
eighth straight year of record sales I'm
talking about spam the 85 year old
product has been undergoing a cultural
reinvention and Hormel says it just
cannot make Spam fast enough so it's
boosting production capacity it is a
trending ingredient on Tick Tock so the
youngsters love it and then it's even on
fine dining menus at restaurants across
the cities I know my boss loves it
spam's popularity with Hawaiian Asian
Pacific island cuisine has certainly
also influenced its growth okay you got
to see this video yes we live in a
desert but no camels aren't exactly a
common sight that is until one decided
it was gonna visit in and out on the
blue diamond last night his name is
Fergie and apparently he loves french
fries this Handler says he's a rescue
from Colorado he now lives in a
sanctuary here in Las Vegas Sherry the
only thing we don't know is whether he
asked for animal fries
of course he did he knows his in and out
better than anybody 6 25 6 26 or should
I say better than any animal all right
here's your accurate day planner for
your Wednesday we've got low 70s right
now for your six o'clock hour on our way
to Upper 70's later this morning mid 80s
for your lunch hour make sure you're
taking extra water with you today as we
dry out a little bit more and 92 for the
afternoon High staying above normal not
totally summer like but definitely
warmer than fall and temperatures will
cool slowly no clouds in the sky today
just full on Sunshine we'll take a look
at some cooler changes how they're
coming up in your most accurate forecast
at 6 30. all righty next year on good
day a new housing development in the
works at Red Rock Canyon but some locals
they're not too happy about it why they
say more development will only make
ongoing problems worse
6 27 you're watching Good Day Las Vegas
live local now
[Music]
they're only three days a week in Fall
it's the law
now on good day dog adoptions at the
animal foundation paused the potentially
deadly illness threatening dozens of
animals new housing approved in Scenic
Red Rock canyons and folks deliver on
their guts and concerns as the developer
plans to build hundreds of homes Plus
the enormity of this project is hard to
Fathom and harder to put into words just
looking at it is pretty darn cool there
is a new show coming to our Las Vegas
strip we'll tell you what it is where it
is and a little bit more about it coming
up here good day Las Vegas starts right
now
now
this is good day Las Vegas live local
now we start here at 6 30 on a Wednesday
morning and you know during the break we
were talking about uh Tom Brady and
Gisele potentially maybe looking for
divorce lawyers and our director said
you can't talk about that you're giving
everyone false hope
for either one of them for either one of
them because they're so good looking
yeah so anyway the rumor mill is
spinning this morning well we wish them
the best we don't you don't like to see
anybody go down that road no especially
when the kids exactly yeah yeah well
there's also a lot going on this morning
so we're keeping our eye on the SpaceX
rocket in Florida
and here at home our temperatures they
won't rock it into the 90s they'll
slowly get up into some warmer
temperatures though and staying above
normal we'll see how long that lasts the
eight day forecast does have some
changes in it so stay tuned for that
this morning it's beautiful nice and
clear yesterday at this hour we had some
clouds in the the sky temperatures were
a little warmer yesterday so down a
little bit cooler with the clear skies
in fact we've got more neighborhoods in
the 60s this morning Wes Henderson on St
Rose Parkway at 65 Nellis is down at 69.
70 degrees in North Las Vegas and at the
airport 72. not much in the way of wind
humidity is down just a little bit and
those dew points are down a little bit
too so a little bit drier air we'll say
71 is a good average temp this morning
kiddos and this afternoon when that Bell
Rings it's still going to be a warm day
we're looking at 92 so hopefully you got
the sunscreen on and ready to go and
you've got extra water in your backpacks
it is going to be a warm Wednesday so
we'll go over the cooler changes coming
up in your most accurate weather now
forecast Nate's keeping his eye on the
drive at 6 32. thank you Sherry we
always have changes on the roads I mean
minute by minute they're going to be a
ton of people on the south 15 then you
get a little bit of a break right now it
looks like there's a lot of folks South
under the 95 515 around the Charleston
curve headed to Boulder Highway we're
going to zoom here onto the 15. so far
not too bad but you know just a couple
of minutes ago it was packed and really
slow going uh here we are this is the
southbound side of the 95 I make that
the I-15 out of the spaghetti bowl with
the World Market Center and Resorts
World in the wind down there meantime
the rest of the freeway system is in
pretty good shape an earlier crash that
has cleared I'm keeping the camera there
to cater and the near the 215 Southern
beltways Decatur and sunset so that
crash is long gone but when we were
looking at this it's like wow there's a
ton of cones down there you drive this
every day you know but big delays
Northbound Decatur that's the 215
Southern Beltway across near the top of
your screen so these folks are
Northbound that Sunset across the middle
of your screen only one lane getting
through there right now Heather yeah a
tough squeeze there Nate we appreciate
that and this morning we know more about
the virus it's impacting the animal
foundation's adoptable dogs and what's
next right now let's put a hold on all
dog adoptions and that's because a newly
fostered dog had to be euthanized after
Contracting an upper respiratory
infection the animal foundation was in
the midst of a public like call for help
at the time because their face was space
was quickly filling up with animals the
foundation says it immediately notified
anyone who took a dog home last week
about possible exposure
you know it is a lethal virus so I'm
afraid that they could succumb to it I
do plan to go to my veterinarian after
this and get some antibiotics to
hopefully prevent anything from
happening that's Jennifer Blanchard and
she took home a foster dog last week and
she is worried her newly fostered dog
might become ill as of right now 17 dogs
at the animal foundation are showing
signs of an upper respiratory illness
other exposed dogs have been quarantined
they're being treated with antibiotics
adoptions for other pets however and
that does include cats have resumed the
shelter though is not sure when it'll be
safe for dogs to be adopted again
yesterday we told you the Nevada State
Police is operating at less than half
staff and this morning we've learned
current and past Personnel believe lack
of pay is forcing Troopers to leave the
job earlier this year 8 news now
investigators revealed starting pay
begins at 55 thousand dollars Metro at
81 000 and in Henderson it's a hundred
thousand dollars
and when you're just the stepping stone
for a lot of the other agencies well
you're you're
it certainly doesn't serve you
right now 65 more Troopers are needed to
make a full staff according to the
Nevada police Union the Department's
last significant pay raise was in 2006.
Nate 6 36 any Wednesday morning to talk
about a Housing Development may be
coming soon to the middle of Red Rock
Canyon some folks who live there not so
happy Clark County commissioned voting
unanimously to continue developing the
first phase of these houses which are
going to be built on Blue Diamond Hill
in the middle of Red Rock Canyon local
developer Jim Rhodes planning to put in
more than 400 houses opponents say hey
that violates county code and previous
legal agreements
I mean eventually you'll probably have
to make it four lanes and the traffic
will have to move more swiftly
um you know it certainly won't have
allowance for someone who very leisurely
wants to view the scenery let's talk
about the two-lane State Highway 159
there's a little town of Blue Diamond so
Mr Rhodes has four years to get uh paved
legal right away from the construction
area over to State Highway 159 that
currently belongs to the Bureau of Land
Management so we're definitely going to
be keeping an eye on that one Sherry
bet well this morning President Biden
and first lady Jill Biden will be in
Florida where they'll get a first hand
look at the devastation left behind by
Hurricane Ian the bidens are expected to
meet with local officials there families
and First Responders rescue teams
continue to go door to door in search of
both victims and survivors hundreds of
thousands of homes and businesses remain
without power getting the lights back on
is a priority but officials there say
that it could take at least a month or
more to do that well one of the ways
that nevadans can help hurricane victims
is simply by donating blood and there
are several blood drives happening this
week including one today at Wells Fargo
near Rainbow and Sahara another one
Thursday at Rainbow Library you can find
out more make an appointment also at Red
crossblood.org Heather
a deadly house fire just two weeks ago
certainly a difficult reminder of how
critical it is to practice and also
prepare your family for emergencies it
is fire prevention month Candace Charles
joining us live at the Clark County
building department Candace you've been
talking about fire extinguishers the
importance of having one but that's not
all you need good morning
good morning to you Heather that is
correct good morning folks as you can
see it's a little smoking here we've got
some flanks going you don't want to wait
until this situation to come up with a
plan so I've got a fire inspector Nick
giulito with me tell me exactly what we
should be doing in a situation like this
situation like this we should have a
plan in place to where there's two
locations that you can exit your house
safely and meet your family and friends
when you do see smoke like this in this
environment you want to keep as low as
possible to the floor with the air is a
little bit cleaner and you want to get
out and stay out all right so we're
going to try to run this drill through
really quickly so you want to stay low
guys and then do you want to touch the
walls just in case you need to guide
somebody with the back of your hand in
case it's too hot you don't want to burn
your hand okay perfect and you should be
looking for an exit here
and you should be reuniting with your
friends Stacy hello and of course as you
create this plan and what other things
should you tell your kids so that
they're prepared for the end of that
plan as well that exit don't go back in
looking for your pets your pets are
smart enough they'll probably make it
out just get get out and stay out
perfect thank you so much Nick for
shouting us we appreciate it of course
we have you covered with all these
details so you can look at it again and
run this with your family on our website
8newsnow.com now from the Clark County
building I'm Candace Charles 8 news now
planning is key Candace good live shot
we love seeing that it's so important to
kind of visualize what could potentially
happen thank you for that
still ahead here on good day our city
welcomes a new one-of-a-kind show what
it is where you can catch it
it's pretty cool
we've got it when we come back just
quick reminder
the Raiders in Chiefs this Monday night
here on Channel 8 kickoff set for 5 P.M
we are the home of your most Raiders
games and we've secured this one Raiders
Chiefs Channel 8 Monday nights
it's gonna be a tough game but we need
the win don't we we need it need it all
right look at this beautiful sunrise as
we cover your most accurate eight to
eight forecast we're in the low 70s now
we'll be warming up through the morning
upper 70's 8 A.M 80's by noon pack that
extra water with you we're looking to
dry out a little bit more today and warm
up right back to some extra warm low
90's 90 around your dinner hour we'll
cool off eventually that sun down now in
the six o'clock hour changes are coming
up in your most accurate weather now
forecast stay tuned for that after the
break 6 40.
Traders games
you're watching Good Day Las Vegas with
John langler Heather Mills Sherry swensk
and Nate Tenenbaum Good Day Las Vegas
live local now 6 44 is the time sorry to
be the bearer of bad news but the
average price for a gallon of regular
gas here in Las Vegas went up another
two cents overnight it's now 554 a
gallon this morning a week ago we're
paying about 32 cents less the average
price of gas only needs to go up seven
more cents here in Las Vegas until we
break the all-time record high a 561
which was set four months ago in June
but relief may be on the way California
governor Gavin Newsom made a decision
that could bring some relief to us here
in Nevada he's decided to make the
seasonal shift to a winter blend about a
month ahead of schedule unless of the
gas Nevada receives comes from
California refineries and economists say
the winter blend is cheaper to produce
and is expected to gradually bring bring
prices down as we transition to Winter
well how about this a new show it's been
described as a Las Vegas spectacle on an
epic scale and that's huge right does it
get bigger than that
epic it's going to be debuting next
month the win take a look
[Music]
well looks like a great show it's called
Awakening and it tells the story of a
hero and her two fellow Travelers as
they seek to reunite two lost lovers
Awakening opens November 7th tickets are
on sale now head over to 8newsnow.com
for a link to purchase it looks like
that they have replaced this is where Le
rev was maybe a little theater
okay yeah okay Dottie fans Donny Osmond
fans this is your chance to call in to
win caller number eight right now wins
four tickets and the VIP experience to
see Donny Osmond Harris that's the
number right there on your screen
702-650-1101 call now we'll take the
eighth caller good luck it's your chance
to win
[Music]
all right
this is happening right now in Florida
SpaceX has its Dragon endurance rocket
on the launch pad in Florida you see the
astronauts right there they're all
suited up and seated in the capsule for
the scheduled launch of its fifth crude
space mission